hi I'm Erik Bosse and the Aquaman movie
finally has a full trailer for us with
some impressive imagery from director
James Wan and Jason Momoa as the rock
starfish stalker that Vinnie chase could
never live up to there's a lot to break
down here visual details you may have
missed and references to the comics so
I'm gonna explain who all these
characters are and what may go down in
the movies so possible spoiler warning
in case my predictions end up being
right let's dive in oh that looks cold
so you know what let's just step on and
then we didn't slowly oh god that's
really bad when you get to the middle
why did I do this my father was a
lighthouse keeper
my mother was queen but life has a way
of bringing people together
[Music]
okay this opening section shows us the
origin of Arthur curry Aquaman as it's
depicted in the recent DC Comics new 52
relaunch that was spearheaded by Geoff
Johns it's now kind of the visionary
behind Warner Brothers DC stuff Arthur's
father is the human Thomas curry he's a
lighthouse keeper an amnesty Maine and
he's being played here by tamara
morrison the new zealand actor who
played Jango Fett and his clones in the
Star Wars prequels I love the imagery of
this opening shot of the storm and
notice how it's lit with two sources of
light the beacon from the lighthouse on
land and the lightning from the squall
over the ocean these two light sources
paralleled the two lives that came
together to create Aquaman Thomas curry
and Queen Atlanta the Atlantean Queen
from Atlantis it's always funny to me
it'd be like I'm a Floridian from
Florida and also my name is Flor Dan we
got like eight proper nouns we just
cycle through Atlanta is played by a
Nicole Kidman and this shot of her
strewn on the rocks could be a nod to
the figure Andromeda from Greek
mythology Andromeda was chained to rocks
to be fed to a monster from the sea god
Poseidon as punishment for her mom's
hubris over their centuries a lot of
artists depicted women chained rocks and
that's often a nod to Andromeda
Andromeda was rescued by Perseus who in
this case is reflected in Thomas curry
moving on
they made me what I am it's alright just
get excited in this section we jump
ahead to Arthur's youth in his visit to
the Boston Aquarium these two bullies
mock him for talking to fish yet don't
have the self-consciousness to realize
that their haircuts are a direct mirror
opposite of each other now this idea of
talking to fish is a nod to Aquaman's
best known power from the classic comics
and the cartoon Super Friends and it is
something that the recent DC EU keeps
making light up you can talk to fish but
this moment shows art they're only knit
with the sea life backing them up
actually listen closer to when arthur
communes with the shark that echo e
sonar sound is inspired by the original
super print sound effect whenever
Aquaman's tried to talk to fish but here
it actually looks pretty cool this whole
moment reminds me a lot of that moment
when Harry Potter was being bullied in
the zoo as he was talking to the snake
and that was long before we realized how
important this ability is to his
backstory in origin kind of like how it
is for Arthur curry here notice the way
James Wan shot frames Arthur with this
massive crack in the glass behind him
this could reflect the way his character
is breaking the barrier between the
world of the sea and the world of man
let's move on
so listen to come aboard here we see the
adult Aquaman in action Jason Momoa
torpedoing toward the submarine and
hopping aboard later in the trailer
there are shots of him actually lifting
this submarine to the surface that's how
he gets in there aboard the sub you can
see Yaya Abdul Mateen the second as the
villain Black Manta he's with an older
man maybe his father the actor has said
that his characters driven by revenge
against Aquaman
so perhaps his father doesn't survive
this fight let's move on I've been
looking for you
your half-brother King arm is about to
declare war upon the surface world the
only way to stop this war is for you to
take your rightful place as king okay a
lot of things going on here
first thing the point about this section
is the music this track is called none
shall live and you may recognize it from
the trailer for the Batman V Superman
Ultimate Edition
we see Mira Amber Heard she's Aquaman's
companion and later wife from the DC
Comics remember we saw her briefly in
Justice League where she showed off her
Hydra Kinesis abilities basically she's
a waterbender but unlike in Justice
League characters don't need to be in
air bubbles to be able to talk to each
other James Wanda's made it so that when
they're underwater they just talk to
each other it's easier the way you don't
do everything
and since characters are just gonna talk
to each other underwater they don't need
to be an air bubble so that they look
dry when they're underwater they're just
surrounded by water the actors only have
to be hosed down dripping wet when
they're out of the water like Amber
Heard is here and mayor sets up the
whole royal conflict of this movie
Arthur's half-brother is king or motion
master played by Patrick Wilson after
giving birth to Arthur on land Atlanta
returned to Atlantis and gave birth to
the pure Atlantean Ormond and he resents
the surface world because of the damage
they've done to the ocean through
pollution and yeah let's not forget
kidnapping orcas blowing up sharks and
farting at the beach he's got a point in
this way we can expect Aquaman to
present a similar conflict to what we've
seen things like Game of Thrones Black
Panther or the story of King Arthur but
in this case our hero is the outcast
bastard son who just happens to be on
the more moral side of this we also get
a shot of the undersea Kingdom of
Atlantis and notice these seven statues
these represent the Seven Kingdoms one
of which is the one at the center of all
this Atlantis the Atlanteans are the
ones riding the sharks meanwhile a
second kingdom is Zemel they're the ones
riding the sea horse sea dragon like
mounts whatever these things are they
have legs and their ruler is Mira's
father King Nereus played by Dolph
Lundgren he might be the one on the
center-left meeting with Ormond center
who rides the steep crocodile creature
it will be Aquaman's mission and movie
to unite the Seven Kingdoms win the
nation of Atlantis sunk to the bottom of
the sea these seven kingdoms split apart
from each other we'll meet some of the
other five kingdoms they haven't
mentioned yet as we go I'll point him
out so it looks like or maybe behind
this tsunami that we see slamming a
massive ship into the shore as part of
his first strike against the land
dwellers Arthur and Thomas survive this
attack you can see mirror there
alongside them maybe she used her
waterbending abilities to rescue them
from the wave and before we move on a
really big detail here we see this shot
of King at lamb who bears this trident
this is actually very critical to the
story of this movie I'll get to that in
a second but first thanks for our
sponsor mr. Koya now you may have
noticed me wearing these stylish shirts
recently these are from mr. Coyle
shirt company that makes quality
short-sleeve button-down shirt designs
that you won't find anywhere else look I
didn't get into this gig planning to be
an on-camera youtuber who thinks about
how I look and yeah my shirt game over
the years not great so when I found mr.
Koya huge game-changer they have some
tone down patterns but also some bolder
ones and all the shirts just feel like
some kind of magical cotton courage
making me think hey I can't be fun we'll
talk about nerd stuff well maybe not as
fun as these models but you know nerd
fun each shirt is kind of its own
character this one is called
Featherstone and I like it because it
reminds me of my Floridian homeland and
the Flamingo is my spirit animal and we
got an amazing offer just for you guys
you can get 20% off your entire order
when he purchased two or more shirts
just by using our promo code new rock
stars just visit mr. Quan comm slash new
rock stars or click on the link in the
description below to look like me well
me between the neck and the waist but I
assume better sculpted I'm just speaking
directly to Jayson mo here I know he
watches ok back to this trident many
were wondering why the weapon aquaman
used a Batman V Superman of Justice
League had 5 spokes unlike the three of
Aquaman's classic Trident that's because
that wasn't his Trident that was a Quint
dn't
or a Penta dent it's the one belonging
to his mother remember you could see her
clutching that in the earlier shots
Aquaman's journey in this movie will be
to recover this ancient shrine and to
prove his claim to the throne the
filmmakers have actually cited classic
movies like Raiders of the Lost Ark and
Romancing the Stone as inspirations for
this story which is really a pursuit for
a lost relic ok on to the next section
trust me I know
do your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all that was the worst pep
talk ever Arthur refuses mirrors initial
call and if you look closely you can see
this green necklace that he's wearing
now at first some thought this could be
a connection to his Atlantean roots but
it's actually a Maori Toki jade necklace
so like the tattoos on his skin it's
actually another nod to his Polynesian
ancestry we also see Mira and Arthur
exploring these ruins various looks at
the set and a shot in an alternate cut
of the trailer shown at comic-con showed
a scene in this location with Arthur and
a hologram of King at land who explains
the powers of the Trident also that
extended cut reportedly showed Aquaman
in a final version of his green and
orange costume moving on I want to strap
in
okay here a shot dives into the water to
bring us into the city of Atlantis which
looks awesome it looks like this has
been built into the sides of a reef and
it has these interesting little details
that looks like a chimney releasing air
bubbles and elaborate tubes that could
run energy from structure to structure
like power lines we also say that
massive sea turtles and whales are
apparently used to transport cargo in
the society and that bioluminescent
jellyfish are the sources of light kind
of like street lights I want to go to
here let's move on
Jasmeet for the throne my god an
ass-whooping
in this section we get a sense of the
atlantean people who participate in
gladiator type events notice how the
crowds are pointing their thumbs down
you may recognize that from the movie
Gladiator that's how the Roman crowds
would signal that they wanted someone to
be executed Aquaman and Orem are
squaring off in some kind of ritual
combat in this arena beside an
underwater volcano which do erupted lava
onto the ocean floor like that though
that means this water that they're in
must be boiling hot making any fight in
this area one hell of an intense cage
match hey if you can't take the heat
stay out of the underwater Kingdom
gladiator arena
I'm guessing this scene will be around
the midpoint of the movie since Arthur
still has his quaint dent maybe he's
trying to take on his half-brother a bit
too early and he's getting beat down
before he rises up and returns for a
rematch later at the end of the movie
moving on
[Music]
here we see a brief glimpse of volcko
that's Arthur's mentor figure played by
Willem Dafoe he hurls the Quinton tin it
crossfades and Arthur as a younger man
on the beach notice how he claps the
weapon right in front of his face the
same way he does in the earlier shot in
the submarine kind of looks like a
signature move for the guy even though
the main events of this movie will take
place after Justice League it looks like
it'll still be an origin story with some
flashbacks to his youth and training
with his training taking place both on
the surface world and underwater
suggesting that Arthur has spent most of
his life in the sort of Exile both and
land and then water just not running
things back in Atlantis yet that's what
this movie is showing us moving on which
is you have two different worlds
that is exactly why you are worthy
here Arthur hugs his father goodbye and
in another shot Queen Atlanta kisses
Arthur as a baby goodbye and we get this
very cool shot of Arthur and mirror with
a flare diverting a massive horde of sea
monsters away from a boat these things
are from another one of the Seven
Kingdoms called the trench notice how
these creatures have no eyes the trench
is way deeper than the other kingdoms it
actually hurts the Atlanteans to go down
there because of water pressures too
intense it's all in a place without
light so their beings have devolve to
lose their eyes completely like many of
the terrifying real-life sea creatures
that are down in those places James Wan
is of course known for his horror films
like saw insidious and the conjuring so
it looks like he'll be bringing in some
of that horror imagery with these trench
people we also see a quick shot of black
manta mera jumping over rooftops in a
foot chase and these interesting looking
beans and this is a fourth one of these
Seven Kingdoms called the fishermen
Kingdom there are relatively peaceful
people one of them is being played by
Djimon Hounsou who also shows up in the
trailer for Shazam as the wizard this
guy's everywhere let's move on to the
surface
and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven
seas with me
[Music]
in this section we get some good looks
at Black Manta with his signature helmet
which is James Wan promises almost
exactly like his appearance in the
comics matter how weird it looks in real
life and that includes the optic blasts
that fire out of his red eye pieces this
helmet is that Lantern tech that was
given to him by King horn these two
villains are teaming up against Aquaman
perhaps or misusing Black Manta as a way
to come after Arthur when he's on land
maybe look closely as this helmet
charges up pre blast you can kind of see
this reddish mist hovering over him now
synthesis underwater technology I'm
wondering if the way this helmet
operates is by harnessing water vapor
from the air thus trailer climaxes with
this epic battle with or leading the
Atlantean charge against another one of
the Seven Kingdoms a race of crustacean
looking creatures these are called the
brine and even though this one's about
to be dipped in butter by orbs mount I
love the way Klausen flings aside this
Atlantean warrior like a rag doll now
there are two remaining kingdoms that
weren't featured in this trailer that we
don't really know anything about yet but
I assume there's a good reason for that
that we'll see in the final movie and
that brings us to this final section
[Music]
okay it's not really clear what's going
on here even the goat looks confused I
think it's kind of a joke
Mira jumps out of the plane without a
parachute ooh this desert dune location
perhaps she plans on trying to use her
hydro Kinesis to absorb what little
moisture exists in the desert air to
cushion her fall either way it's no
surprise how much Arthur loves a good
skydive he spent like 20 minutes of
Justice League reenacting Point Break
and then one last miserable dito here
the pilot of this plane is a cameo this
is Leigh Whannell James Juan's longtime
co producer and actor in the saw an
insidious movies he just directed
upgrade okay a question for you guys
what other DC EU hero would he like to
cameo in this movie I don't like the way
the flash made a cameo in Suicide Squad
it could be cool for a short and sweet
sighting from another Justice leaguer
like Wonder Woman or Superman maybe a
new one
ghrelin washer man owner comment down
below with your thoughts art Whitney ID
Avis and follow new rock stars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
this video share it around and subscribe
to new rock stars for our breakdowns of
more of these comic-con trailers Sam's
actually covering Shazam but we'll also
be looking at Godzilla king of monsters
and crime tracker are gone thank you for
watching and I'm gonna go swimming bye
[Music]